thank you well good evening ladies and
gentlemen members uh and good evening we
have a member of the public here
um and welcome to the Joint
Transportation board
uh we will start with
a little bit of housekeeping it's we're
not expecting a fire alarm so if it's
activated please vacate to the building
via the stairs
and please do not use the lifts
I suspect we won't be assembling in
Hawley Square on the green tonight but
officers will of course assist you
mobile phones could everyone present
please ensure their mobile phone is
switched to silent and that they're not
used to make or receive calls in the
chamber while this meeting is in
progress
this is being filmed for the public if
filming takes place here anyone in the
tenants in the public area may have
their image captured so
I'm not sure if anyone is actually going
to be filming tonight and I'm getting a
shake of the head so we'll move on
um does any member wish to speak under
20.1
in which case we will go straight on to
the gender item one which is apologies
uh apologies for absence any other odd
Proteus or absence we already have
Council shonk I believe
Barry Lewis
and Rob Yates
and councilor Comfort thank you any
others thank you very much we are
quarate so we all continue agenda item
two is Declarations of Interest are
there any Declarations of Interest
No Agenda items three uh the minutes of
the joint Transportation board meeting
held on the 12th of October which I was
not present at but our
council is happy to approve this and
sign is a correct so it can be signed as
a correct record can I have a proposer
please
uh councilor Derek Brown Corral Brown
and the seconder councilor scoby all
happy with that
thank you very much
um tonight we move on before we move on
to agenda item four
um as all of you are aware we have been
a form that the area manager and Richard
heaps will not be attending tonight I
have spoken to Simon Jones who is the
corporate director for highways who if
um something could be arranged is happy
for officers to attend either in office
hours or online if outside of office
hours
um did you wish to speak at all on this
or have you any updated
um okay in which case
um members if they would kindly let me
know at some point if you are interested
in a solution uh which is either
on like we could also possibly do online
if the agreement is changed between us
and between TDC and KCC but
um
I welcome comments on whether you would
prefer to have this during the day so
that the public can participate
or in the evening online
um I think this is something we've got
to think about because
there is only one way for the public to
participate and that is if it's here in
in the chamber at the moment
and I'm not sure that uh we could Well
we I'm not sure if we could at present
cope with
a higher bread or no we couldn't
Council right
um I I just might sound a little bit off
the wall but
um is there any reason why we could if
we if we could have a meeting and as a
link to the officers that would be fine
but we can't live stream
so could we not have I know it's
expensive to make it into a hybrid
meeting but would the answer not be
maybe a video camera so that the meeting
is videoed in the chamber and then
posted after the meeting
uh would you like to answer a little on
that because I'm not aware of what TDC
has or does not have here if that if
that's okay chair thank you
um now excuse my ignorance because it
isn't my area of expertise it is
democratic services but uh it's to do
with the legislation and how we hold the
meetings so they have to be held in
accordance with a Government Act and I
don't want to say which one it is
because I'll get it wrong and so that's
the reason why we can't I've either got
to be live streamed
you know to to be able to be in
accordance with that act so that's
that's the difficulty
because it changed in covert we could do
things differently it's now gone back to
the original act and we can't do it that
way
as much as we might like to find a
solution
this is a work in progress
um there are all sorts of solutions that
have been offered but um it is very much
in the lap of um of TDC as to what they
can or cannot do here
um so moving on we have agenda item four
which is parking places for disabled
persons Vehicles that's Pages 9 to 16.
um
have you members who have read this and
have any comments
any comments at all
that's a scoby I think we should
advertise these people leave the the
spaces
well the recommendations are
um we're recommended to
uh
to go for option one that the parking
places for disabled persons Vehicles as
listed in Annex one would be exposed to
formal public consultation
um our members happy to agree that
thank you and uh
the second part of that is that the
proposals which require statutory
consultation are advertised and that any
traffic related objections are reported
back to a future meeting of the board
now if you're happy to agree that I'd
like a proposer
for that kelsoscobee and a secondary
counselor right
and we're happy to agree
thank you
agenda item five is the highway Works
program
sorry I'll just have to move down
to that are there any comments on this
program
no
um I do have some comments myself on
this and I will start with uh agenda
item five b
which if we go through this first of all
there was if you'd like me to go through
them one by one I'm happy to do so the
the road Footwear and Cycle Way renewal
and preservation schemes appendix a were
there any uh questions on that
nope
then we've got a gender item
appendix B which is drainage repairs and
improvements now I'm not sure what other
members think but I noticed that
there are a lot of drainage problems all
over than it and many of them are caused
by seem to be caused by a lack of Street
clearing
if there aren't leaves to go down the
drains you don't get blocks
and that's something I think I
personally would like to recommend that
we
we note
for TDC that unfortunately some of that
lack of cleaning streets is causing
extra costs in terms of drainage repairs
when somebody else has to come out and
clean the drains
and that seems to be a big problem now I
don't know if other members have also
found that
account Council quitness
we have this we have a big problem with
this invisible I mean rural areas are
all particularly badly uh affected in
terms of trees and leaves and so on and
so forth I mean my understanding of this
is a lot this is contracted out I mean
we've had instances in Minster whereby
they'll come and clear a gully and if
another girl who's brought to their
retention like 20 feet away they can't
do it's not on there it's not on their
list and there's all sorts of problems
in that direction but I mean I did ask a
long time ago about a schedule of uh
Gully cleaning but that doesn't seem
it's just the only time has been come to
our area at least is just on report or
full so yeah I mean is there any
scheduled cleaning the garage do we know
uh I don't know maybe you know
sorry
sorry
it is KCC that do the Gully cleaning I
don't believe there is a schedule for it
I believe that it is done on reports but
I can't say that for gospel truth we can
go back and ask that so Stephen can do
that in the minutes we'll take back and
ask them
um I'll turn it round a little bit is
there any schedule for street cleaning
because it seems to me that um and this
is TDC
and that's where the problem starts the
leaves are piling up on the Pavements in
the gutters and then that's causing the
problems with the guys
um and is there any uh program of street
cleaning or is that something that's
been left
to
fate
maybe you can answer that
I can do my best
also don't know the actual answer
um but yes there is excuse me there is
some schedule of street cleaning I don't
know what that is it's not within my
area of knowledge but we will find that
out and give it back to you when we know
exactly what it is I'm going to suggest
that
in terms of blocked gullies it's going
to take years worth of leaves to cause a
blockage that then causes the road to
flood
um it's something that yeah definitely
needs to be looked at as a whole with
KCC and we can take that forward
I might discussed that with you at a
later date on a Year's worth of leaves
because um I know from personal
experience that
it went from one winter to another in
certain areas where there are lots of
leaves and I think it's used to be
cleaned
um and isn't now and of course there are
other dangers because if Pavements
aren't cleaned at all
those leaves become slippery and if
people slip that's an insurance job and
that's going to come back
to TDC okay
we've had so much rain as well it's
obviously the leaves are getting very
slippery and I have I've had residents
you know inquire about this and we do
have schedules but they're intimate you
know you're not having it it's not
intermittent I should say so they're not
as often as they should be but we there
is a schedule for them
um but obviously all the rain and all
the leaves and the wind and everything
we've had in over the last month or so
is obviously made it a lot worse
so but that's not an excuse It's just
what it is okay thank you any other
comments
um going on as Panic C is Street
lighting
um
any comments on that part of the
report
which case we move on to 5D
which is a casualty reduction measures
um
and you will note that North down road
is there I'd rather save that for
the next agenda item but are there any
other comments at all
no let me go on to
uh
appendix C which is developer funded
works
I have one question sorry any other
question any questions at all
I have one question which I will ask
but I I suspect I will have to put that
to an officer to KCC which is I noticed
that Reading Street Road is on there and
as far as I know there are several that
along with other applications is still
in appeal so it almost looks as though
it's awaiting submission I'm quite short
awaiting submission
is but um
it's quite misleading because it looks
as though it would appear as though it's
there as Works to be done
but it may never get through is that
correct you know I don't you know sorry
okay it's one that we'll have to ask and
if you if
if members are agreed I will put those
questions to the area manager okay
agree yep
then
I think that was the end of the
dependencies for that yep in which case
um if there are no other questions this
report is for information so we'll
members note the report happy to do so
yeah thank you
moving on
I hate doing this
looking at this at the same time is very
very difficult
um
we're moving on to agenda item six which
is the casualty reduction measures for
North down road now this has already
been signed off this was deferred from
the last meeting
in June we are noted down in one of the
reports at KCC we're noted down actually
as having
um been in approving of this
um well supporting it certainly and
which is quite strange because at the
time the Dune committee actually
said that they were quite interested in
having 20 mile per hour signs there now
this has been signed off already by the
cabinet member
to proceed which does not mean that we
can't comment on it
and most of the scheme
should have been con should have been
commented on earlier we didn't
I see no reason why we can't put in our
opinions even so it's quite a lengthy
it's quite a lengthy scheme and I don't
know if everyone's in ready to say that
they approve of it or not
so I'd welcome any comments on this
unfortunately you know Lewis and Council
her game aren't here
and it would affect their areas I
believe more than anyone
Council scoby have you got anything to
say on this no no I approve of the
scheme
the only problems not having officers
here to question it which is why it
didn't get uh
moved on
well
um I'm not particularly happy that uh
it's been signed off without any
comments at all and that I think is not
acceptable
and I suspect that it's actually a
governance issue for KCC
which I will be bringing up
since I chair that committee
councilor fellows yeah thank you chair
um I presume everybody else got the
email back on the 25th of October from a
resident of cliftonville but he said
that the shopkeepers in cliftonville had
received an email from KCC stating that
the work was approved
by the JTB on the 15th of October which
yes which was of course not true yeah
just um I just wanted to make sure
everybody else was aware of that yeah
um I noticed also that in the
consultation which was
um I believe 25 days the first of the
25th of July uh statutory is 21 days
for a consultation
but actually they the report which is
here it does say that it was recommended
by the department that does these
consultations was recommended to
actually do a larger a longer
consultation that was not carried out
it was not approved there were a couple
of things there as well that um I found
the impact on uh there was no
consideration of the impact on business
there was impact on residents and
possibly those who were
had Mobility problems would have to walk
a little further but it was not
mentioned at all in the consultation
report or the impact report
on equality it was not mentioned at all
that it might have an impact on
businesses
um which I find surprising because of
course if you can't walk that far you're
not going to go to those businesses uh
the only thing that was said was that
the the total number of
parking spaces in or around about
Northtown Road would be more or less the
same
which is not quite the same as
being able to park on the street there
but um but I'm happy to take any other
comments if we if we have problems with
this in any way then it's not too late
to put those comments in writing
even if it's been signed off
because
as I said I think that they should have
had further a better consultation than
that
okay in which case we are asked to note
that and move on to the next item
and the next item is agenda item seven
which is the proposed 20 mile per hour
speed limit psalmiston Dane Valley
um
again this was supported by councilor
Lewis who's not here
has anyone else any comments to make on
this Council fellows
yeah thanks chair can I just ask what
the command members Grant will be for
the coming year
I don't know there will be one
okay because I um I'm led to believe
that this this schemes to be funded only
from councilor Lewis's combined member
Grant so I mean I'm not sure how it's
going to be funded if you're not getting
one
um I don't know if there'll be one
because the budget has not been set yet
um
there are divided opinions on that
um I think it's fair to say
um
I noticed it cost seventeen thousand it
covers a huge amount of
um Margate
um frankly
um it's in an area where most of the
speed surveys show that it's only viable
because most people are doing about 24
25 miles an hour anyway
and it costs 17 000 pounds which
actually I think is quite cheap
considering how big how vast this you
know the area is that it covers
um
and whilst I have no particular opinion
on it myself I just think that it's a
very large area
um and there's no funding for it
there is no funding from KCC and
um the so I would suspect that there
would not be enough funding in one
member Grant
um
whether another Margate Council or
mother and other KCC counselor with a
member grant that
would be prepared to support it I don't
know
many other comments
nope
do we have a recommendation for This Is
Us
sorry
for the speed limit we made as
advertised pen not confirmed
4.1
yeah just before the
right there we go
okay the recommendation
uh that the tro for the speed limit be
made as advertised Penny confirmed
identification of funding
to me this is actually a waste of our
time because
um without funding it's going nowhere
um
and personally I think um you know
to start advertising something which
nobody's going to fund at least for the
time being is a difficult one I I I mean
in no way to stop it if people feel that
it's worth doing
but uh
opinions please councilor scoby I
definitely think it's worth doing in
view of the um the family nature of the
the areas and I think it's three primary
schools it says in the report
and it sets a tone uh for the rest of
Planet I know that Ramsgate are pressing
for a blanket 20 mile per hour speed
limit and as mentioned before on North
down Road uh we expressed an interest in
a 20 mile per hour speed limit it wasn't
brought in I think it's the way forward
thank you Council Scooby councilor Curry
Brown you look as though you want to say
something right okay yeah I'm a funny
area board committee we're we're all for
these 20 mile an hour zones but as said
before it's a
case of funding uh unfortunately uh
Margate Dane Valley haven't got a Town
Council uh
where they can get the funds from their
precept
um
well our members
happy to recommend that they go ahead
with this
can I have
that proposed then that she would
recommend that
uh
speed limit is advertised well the tro
is advertised
seconder Council scoby
other members
I also get very concerned
in the in the past is it in terms of
enforcement of all these areas that were
introduced or trying to introduce I mean
has there been any update on whether the
police are going to get physically
involved in enforcing these limits the
reason that the um the the KCC reason or
the highways reason
um for only putting them in where people
already are more or less obeying the
speed limit
is that uh without enforcement they are
the signs are
um pretty much useless and I will say
that
in many places I would suspect that I
throw this open for common but I would
suspect that in London where they have a
lot of 20 mile per hour people would not
be traveling 20 miles per hour at night
time if they didn't know that there were
cameras every few yards
so uh and
whilst I I have no problem with the 20
mile per hour speed limit
um I just question whether it's um
as useful
as many think in in an area where people
are already
traveling relatively slowly
the the four or five miles per hour
might might or might not make a
difference I'm not sure scoby
with things like the changes in the
highway code where we're supposed to
respect pedestrians and respect uh
cyclists and so on I I think it it um
places
a duty on kcct TDC to actually address
these issues in a positive way and I
think you know the 20 is 20
um
scheme has been vocal for a long time
and I think we're gradually creeping
towards it I believe that in Wales
they're going to do a national
20 mile per hour speed limit so it's
coming everywhere thank you okay so we
have a proposal we have a second are we
happy to agree
with recommendation
that is actually how many one two three
four
that agreed
that's all right okay
uh still the majority so
um yeah they disagree that we go for the
recommendation
we're going to give the recommendation
yep
um they have it here in writing
four to three
was that a a negative or an abstention
yeah sorry I've just like no until the
uh the um the funding is
made available or identified I don't
think it's not worth giving any more uh
work to our officers if if the funding's
not there and to be found sir thank you
Council right
well I agree with cancer fellows yeah
and I think it should be noted that
three feel that until the family is
found it is possibly
um
not something that they would commit to
the time being okay uh that
ladies and gentlemen is the last agenda
item as said it's not very satisfactory
because we can't ask questions and I
think we have to look at ways of moving
this forward so that we can get
participation yes sorry it's just a
quick before we close the meeting for
those of you that are interested one of
my colleagues who is watching online hi
Charles has that put through that it's
the Local Government Act 1972
um is what we have the meetings under so
if you want to look it up and read it
that's what it is thank you
thank you very much
um it's I would rather have them online
and have people participating and I'm
I'm not sure if that's the way forward
but I feel that if that is the way that
we can do it but unfortunately that's
not very good for democracy it means
that the public
kind of well unless the public can watch
but not have any um
any input as such unless they're invited
to speak
but I just feel that we have to move
this forward we can't just continue to
not say anything
is there a big problem
uh
as I suggested we could have it in the
daytime
and then that is accessible to everyone
if we had it in the daytime
apart from members
that is true but they are only once
every three months so
um it's you know it's not something that
Springs up every week or something but
uh that is a Way Forward
and I think it's something that I'd be
happy to for you to think about and come
back to me on
and I'll put that forward that would get
officers here
okay
yeah as I said it is only once a once
every three months and we're not talking
about a regular basis anyway but let me
know what you think I'll be a pre you
know I'd appreciate that an email
something just a or a phone call please
okay thank you very much for attending
tonight meeting is closed